it just so happens we have on our video
call I think we've brought them in we
have someone who's a tight rope
instructor Sonya harps dead she teaches
at the circus warehouse here in New York
Sonya do we have you on the line yeah
I'm here Oh Sonya hello thanks for being
on Startalk hi it's great to be here
yeah so so I did I guess we know
intellectually that people such as
yourself exist but to really see you you
teach people highwire stunt yes that's
that's a correct statement okay so what
kind of mindset does it take to do to
tip who comes to you to do this that's
really what I should be asking here well
you know the funny thing is that a whole
range of people come to us and it's
really interesting to see who's
interested in the challenge are we we
teach the wire is not that high so it's
not a fear thing it's really more about
finding a way to get your body do
something that's really challenging so
are you saying you can actually teach
this skill is not just some some
psychological state of the person who
finds you well and a little bit you also
teach the psychological state but you
can absolutely teach tightwire walking
anyone can walk a tight wire and when
did this begin in your life when I was
in high school I want a vacation and
they had a flying trapeze sir and when I
jumped off I just knew I was going to do
this for us my life so I found some
classes and I worked on it through
college and at the end of undergrad it
was med school or the circus and I chose
the circus so you tell me but Polly by
age 17 you were in a position to tell
your parents you want to run away and
join the circus that's what you're
telling me here yeah
very cool well show you thanks for
sharing some time with us on Startalk
thanks for having me go I'll come watch
you one day and what you can take
physics notes and we'll compare notes
absolute okay what what law physics kept
you alive and what would have killed you
had you messed up okay alright thanks
Sonia all right no prob thank you all
right